the biden economy is continuing to fail
on every front tonight inflation surging
40-year high gas prices now at a record
high once again the stock market
continues to tumble hammering americans
retirement accounts
especially the poor middle income and
people on fixed incomes all while all
while the biden white house continues to
blame everyone but themselves and
according to gallup americans are now
taking notice with a whopping 52 percent
of voters saying they are worried about
maintaining their very standard of
living so while the left may try to
distract from all of these failures and
try to fuel more hysteria and blind rage
against the u.s supreme court abide in
self-inflicted crises is staring
americans right in the face at the gas
pump and in the grocery aisle and pretty
much every service every good you buy at
every store you go to here with reaction
south carolina senator lindsey graham is
with us senator welcome back there's not
a single thing i can point to that the
democrats can run on
uh and say we've been successful here
there or anywhere uh they seem to have
now locked into an extreme position
on abortion and even supporting
doxing these supreme court justices now
wednesday of this week we are expecting
a chuck schumer
vote to codify roe
do we know the language in that bill
how extreme is it
well it doesn't codify roe what it would
do is allow abortion to be had right up
to the moment of birth that's not roe v
wade roe v wade says the state can
regulate abortion uh after viability of
the fetus is about 23-24 weeks this goes
well beyond row so their answer to roe v
wade being potentially repealed is to
nationalize a law that allow abortion
right up to the moment of birth uh
that's pretty extreme this will be a
referendum joe biden's economic and
national security policy it won't be a
referendum on roe v wade the election in
2022 will be decided about you can't buy
a baby formula i bet 100 of americans
believe that if you have a baby and you
bring a baby in the world should be able
to buy formula well there's a crisis
when it comes to baby formula you can't
fill up your gas tank i spent 65 dollars
fill it out my gas tank today and it was
three quarters uh
and that was just three quarters the
border is broken this is going to be
referendum abide not roe v wade three
things should happen here joe biden
should look the camera in the eye and
tell every protester leave the judge's
home
home alone you're committing a crime it
is illegal to go try to intimidate a
judge who's hearing the case at their
home like it would be a juror uh joe
biden needs to say that we all ask trump
to tell the protesters to leave the
capitol president biden here's what i
want you to do i want you to get on
television and tell these people to
leave the judges alone because they're
committing their crime i'd like to see
police insurance
on the same time the problem with your
advice is that ship has sailed the
administration has already said people
are free to protest in front of supreme
court justice's home so they've already
given their tacit approval
well number two i'm going to write a
letter tomorrow to the attorney general
garland and ask him what is his
interpretation there's a law on the
books that prevents judges from being
harassed and picketed while they're
deciding a case same for a juror they're
literally violating the law they
violated the law when they went into the
capitol uh trespassing in the capital
taking matters in their own hands
everybody yelled at trump tell them to
leave well here's what i'm telling
president biden tell these people to
leave the judges alone don't go to their
home this is illegal it's wrong it's bad
for america it will break the court joe
biden needs to step up and take matters
into his own hands and as president
united states speak forcefully to these
people are intimidating judges trying to
get an outcome in a case which violates
our law attorney general guard garland
you need to issue an opinion tomorrow
saying that the activity in front of the
judge's house violates the law i i i'd
like the attorney general the way in i'd
like the fbi director ray to weigh in
i'd like the dhs secretary i said just
last week that domestic
domestic terrorism was the biggest
threat society has uh don't you think
it's a little bit dangerous allowing
people to show up in front of the homes
of supreme court justices uh when
they're facing an important decision
isn't that intimidation harassment and
the type of thing i think the law is
very clear it shows is
illegal well it's illegal to go into the
capitol we all agree with you you and i
and everybody else with a half a brain
said leave the capital this is not the
way to deal with an election so
president biden you have an opportunity
here to get people to stand down before
somebody gets hurt what they're doing
president biden is a violation of the
law you need to speak up attorney
general garden garland you need to issue
an opinion tomorrow telling these people
they're in violation of law they keep
doing it they're going to jail if you
don't do that then you're giving cover
to illegal behavior i think the
president should have been the one to do
it and he passed on it multiple times so
i would argue anything that does happen
he's responsible for uh it's amazing
they didn't care about the riots in 2020
they don't care about this they only
cared about the one riot and um because
they could bludgeon somebody else but
they forgot the important part donald
trump authorized the use of national
guard troops and the people that had the
authority to call them up didn't call
them up that day uh senator senator
thank you that went out of thing he said
yes sir he said leave he told him to
leave the capitol will biden tell him to
leave the judges alone at home do what
trump did he told him to leave you need
to tell him to leave
all right senator thank you coming up
another day another scandal for zero
experience hunter biden hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else